poetas filósofos sacerdotes sociólogos
antropólogos psicólogos economistas até
médico já falaram sua felicidade e eu
continuo achando que vale a pena a gente
falar sobre esse tema porque ele é o
principal de gestão nossa vida
existe um ditado chinês que diz o
seguinte se você quer ser feliz por um
dia fiquei bêbado
se você quer ser feliz por uma semana
como um porco
se você quer ser feliz por um mês se
case
mas se você quer ser feliz a vida
inteira seja um jardineiro
isso remete a gente a ideia de que a
felicidade algo que pode ser construída
algo pode ser cultivada e que a gente
pode zelar por ela
a imagem de um jardineiro é perfeita pra
gente falar sobre bem estar e felicidade
eu trabalho instituições de ensino
pesquisa e assistência e confesso que
fiquei um pouco cauteloso ao tentar
levar o tema felicidade para ser
discutido nesses locais
procurei trazer como exemplo
instituições elevada reputação técnica
mas que colocavam esse tema para
discussão como a clínica mayo e o mestre
era o rosto em boston essas instituições
já colocam a felicidade na pauta de
discussão e de fato uma instituição de
saúde ela podia ter duas categorias de
indicadores a primeira para quem procura
o cuidado não é o tipo de resultado
alcançado pelo diagnóstico que eu tenho
nessa instituição
o qual é o tipo de experiência que as
pessoas têm que se cuidar em aí mas pra
quem trabalha dentro da instituição o
principal indicador é o com feliz eu
possa ser trabalhando aqui dependendo da
perspectiva histórica e cultural
pode ter alguma nuance quando se fala de
felicidade no taoísmo total
falava se que a felicidade tinha a ver
com o alinhamento com a natureza
buda trazia a importância do treinamento
da mente nessa
jornada mas havia na índia dizia que a
violência era um impedimento para a
felicidade
aristóteles palavra que o caminho da
felicidade era feito através da prática
do bem
os japoneses têm um conceito ricci guy é
um espaço da vida da gente onde se
encontra a paixão a vocação a missão e
os nossos ofícios o dólar é um
economista contemporâneo que diz que a
felicidade é o somatório dessas
experiências de prazer e de propósito
que temos ao longo da vida
mas independente de como a gente defina
a felicidade que é seja na dimensão
hedônica relacionado aos gozos ou
dimensão eudaimonia ligado a propósito a
felicidade depende das nossas ações
como é que a gente percebe a felicidade
é matéria de estudo e os estudiosos
especialistas no assunto acreditam que
possa existir um ponto de equilíbrio
nessa percepção é como se fosse um local
para onde retornar se a nossa sensação
de bem estar
mesmo após uma experiência negativa
quando ela cai mas tende a melhorar ao
longo do tempo ou após uma experiência
positiva quando a gente tem um pico mas
que contempla também tende a retornar
esse é um ponto que é determinado
geneticamente acredita naquele momento
em que o dna de nossa mãe nosso pai se
combina esse ponto determinado 50%
daquilo que a gente percebe de bem estar
pode estar relacionado a esse componente
genético 10% pode estar relacionado às
circunstâncias e 40% é um espaço de
manobra que a gente tem que a gente pode
decidir a nosso favor
no que diz respeito a esse componente
genético queria apresentar um estudo que
foi feito há pouco tempo por
pesquisadores de stanford questionando
isso essa efeito implacável do
determinismo genético
eles avaliaram aptidão física ea
capacidade metabólica das pessoas
através de um ensaio genético e
colocaram as pessoas para fazer uma um
esforço um teste de esforço e um desafio
alimentar
depois de um tempo propositalmente eles
informaram as pessoas
o contrário do que aquilo que era
determinado geneticamente quem tinha uma
elevada aptidão era dito que não tinha e
vice versa
colocaram de novo as pessoas para fazer
o teste o que aconteceu
as pessoas se comportaram como a maneira
como elas foram informadas à mente
acabou sendo mais poderosa do que os
genes
isso é para ser refletido do ponto de
vista desse determinismo genético
eu sou um colorista clínico e
freqüentemente me deparo com as pessoas
com muito medo se sentindo ameaçadas e
isso é que me deixa convicto de que a
morte é uma bela oportunidade para a
vida ser valorizada
é por isso que tanto os filósofos ao
longo do tempo colocam à morte com uma
oportunidade para valorizar a vida
ai de quem tem uma clássica frase que
diz se eu levar à morte pra minha vida
reconhecê la e aceitá la de frente
reduzirem ansiedade da morte e também a
mesquinhez da vida e só assim serei
livre para ser eu mesmo
certa vez foi feita uma pesquisa com
pacientes em cuidados de fim de vida
tentando identificar as principais
queixas dos pacientes eram cinco as
queixas
na primeira ela ter tido a coragem de
viver uma vida verdadeira pra mim e não
para que os outros queriam a segunda
queixa não tem trabalhado santo
e aqui cabe um questionamento se de fato
de trabalhar tanto como é trabalhar
naquilo que a gente ama a terceira
queixa era ter tido a coragem de
expressar meus sentimentos a quarta era
ter estado mais com os meus amigos ea
quinta que isso aí pra mim mais
dramática era tem me permitido ser mais
feliz
a felicidade ela não pode ser um tema
para se deixar para o final da vida
eu acho que a gente se preocupa muito
com a morte a gente ocupa muito o nosso
tempo da vida com a morte ela vai nos
alcançar em algum momento não é uma
escolha nós
a gente podia se dedicar mais para
afirmar a vida ontem viveu nos anos 1500
e ele dizia o seguinte o homem que teme
sofrer já está sofrendo pelo que ele
teme que também falava que a minha vida
foi cheia de desgraças
a maior parte delas nunca aconteceu
enquanto a gente ocupa a nossa mente com
medo da morte o com que o futuro pode
não trazer escapa entre os dedos da mão
aquilo que a gente tem de mais valioso
que é o presente
o que a gente pode fazer sobretudo
aquele nosso espaço de 40 por cento para
melhorar a nossa percepção de bem estar
a nossa felicidade os estudiosos apontam
que a gente tem uma série de ações que
poderiam ser feitas nesse sentido é como
se fosse uma caixa com instrumentos uma
caixa de ferramenta que a gente podia
lançar mão e dessas eu queria destacar
33 instrumentos
o primeiro é a atenção ao presente
momento o segundo é a gratidão
e o terceiro é a meditação para começar
várias tradições já falam viva o
presente esteja presente naquilo que
você faz é trazer a nossa atenção para
aquilo que estamos fazendo agora é
fundamental nesse estudo foi avaliar o
efeito que a mente que fica vagando trás
do ponto de vista emocional
os investigadores enviava uma mensagem
às pessoas recebiam uma mensagem num
aplicativo elas respondiam o que elas
estavam fazendo qual era a percepção de
bem estar que elas tinham se elas
estavam ou não pensando se estivessem
pensando ser um pensamento positivo
neutro ou negativo o que eles
encontraram existe uma nítida diferença
na percepção de bem estar
entre as pessoas que tinham um
pensamento neutro eo pensamento negativo
não estar com a mente no presente
momento tem um custo emocional
eu não quero simplificar demais a
questão mas a gente pode fazer escolhas
melhores a nosso favor
etiene de labute foi contemporâneo de
montanha escreveu um clássico livro
chamado o discurso da servidão
voluntária
foi incrível como é que esse texto foi
fonte de inspiração da revolução
francesa para lutero os anarquistas e
praia grande
era um texto que fala de liberdade
palavra de escolhas e como agente
voluntariamente se coloca numa posição
de cervo
sem opção quando na realidade a gente
tem escolha para fazer a gente pode
transpor isso para a questão da
felicidade e para o bem-estar quantas
vezes temos a opção de escolher o nosso
favor e abrimos mão disso uma outra
imagem que eu queria trazer porque ela
inspira a confiança da ave que pousa
sobre um galho onde aquela deposita
confiança no galho são mais rasas que
ela confia em uma das asas representa o
discernimento uma outra asa significa o
desapego discernimento entendendo o
autoconhecimento a nossa capacidade de
reconhecer nossas fraquezas nossos
limites das nossas virtudes e as nossas
forças internas
quando a gente reconhece esses limites
se faz necessário escolhas e aí é que
entra a asa do desapego cada um de nós
tem um conjunto de forças internas de
potência interna
célia irmã que foi um dos pais da
psicologia positiva acredita que são 24
forças internas distribuídos em
sabedoria coragem humanidade justiça
temperança e transcendência
cada um desses grupos têm um conjunto de
forças internas na sabedoria por exemplo
a curiosidade a criatividade a mente
aberta o amor por aprender ea
perspectiva a questão não é se é melhor
ter uma força interna ou outra
a questão é se naquilo que a gente faz
no dia a dia as nossas cinco principais
forças internas estão colocadas
isso tem a ver com alto conhecimento se
a gente coloca as cinco principais
forças internas naquilo que a gente faz
a nossa percepção de que está cansado
com o trabalho não existe a nossa chance
de ter sucesso é maior que a nossa
possibilidade de ser feliz também está
alinhado com a idéia do autoconhecimento
isso está alinhado com aquele conceito
japonês de qinghai que fala de paixão
vocação e missão e ofício que encontra o
seu e que guy vive eles vivem mais tempo
dentro dessas forças internas
uma delas merece um destaque porque a
gente pode cultivar ela independente
dela ter ou não presente nas nossas
cinco principais forças internas
muito se fala dela e ela é o segundo
instrumento que eu queria destacar que a
gratidão ser grato do ponto de vista
neurocientífico ativa zonas especiais do
cérebro com uma face medial do córtex
pré frontal como é que se estuda isso o
efeito da gratidão porque ela pode ter
uma implicação prática na vida da gente
foi feito esse ensaio em que pegou um
grupo de pessoas e dividiu de uma
maneira aleatória em três subgrupos um
grupo ao final do dia redigia queixas
um segundo grupo exigia simplesmente
memórias ou lembranças que viesse na
mente e um terceiro grupo
voluntariamente intencionalmente
agradecia por qualquer fato de grande ou
pequeno significado mas as pessoas a
credenciam que o estudo verificou o
otimismo ea percepção de bem estar de
quem agradecia era maior do que nos
outros dois grupos
isso durou semanas de impacto como eu
disse as zonas especiais do cérebro são
ativadas quando a gente assumir uma
atitude de agradecimento e é claro que a
gente tem muita coisa pra agradecer isso
tem uma importância pedagógica porque a
gente pode ensinar o ambiente a ser
grato
a gente pode falar para os nossos filhos
que vale a pena agradecer no final do
dia
isso aumenta nossa percepção de bem
estar
existem outras medidas que podem ser
feitas para aumentar essa nossa
percepção de felicidade e cello lima
também conheci teresa um perna que vai
de emoção positiva de engajamento de mim
em significado dos relacionamentos e de
acompanhamento que são as entregas
mas eu queria agora destaca o terceiro
elemento dessas dessas ferramentas que a
gente pode utilizar o nosso favor que a
meditação
a meditação da mesma maneira que a
atividade física gera benefício físico e
mental gera benefícios para a nossa vida
entender como é o processo da mente
quando a gente observa o presente
momento tem benefício no nosso dia a dia
do ponto de vista científico neuro
científicamente falando a prática
contemplativo a meditação ativa zonas
especiais do cérebro
existem três dimensões principais que
são melhoradas com a prática da
meditação
primeiro ela amplia nossa capacidade de
atenção e isso tangencia várias coisas
que eu já falei aqui
a meditação melhor o nosso padrão
reativo a maneira como a gente reage a
estímulos externos ea meditação também
amplia nossa capacidade de auto
conhecimento
eu não acredito que a meditação seja só
uma técnica para ampliar nossa
capacidade de resiliência ou de tolerar
a eventos difíceis na vida até
geneticamente já existem evidências de
que o aparato enzimático envolvido com a
epigenética modifica
depois de um dia de prática enzimas como
as 17 lazes sobe no nível sanguíneo de
um dia de prática de um praticante
experiente e isso pode abrir uma avenida
de explicação porque que essas técnicas
geram benefício na nossa saúde
o instituto nacional do câncer
a gente tem um projeto há mais de dois
anos chamado plenamente inca
estimula e tem um espaço para que os
funcionários meditem ao longo da semana
e também na pediatria
os pais os responsáveis os funcionários
também as crianças pratiquem a técnica
de meditação e é bem interessante que
depois de uma breve prática de dez
minutos de uma mãe que nunca tinha feito
meditação ela falou surpresa pra gente
foi a primeira vez depois de todo esse
tempo que eu não pensei na minha filha
ao acompanhar essas pessoas se
aproximando da morte
a gente precisa chamar vida trazer a
nossa atenção presente momento
exercitar em a gratidão pelo que a gente
tem pelo que a gente é pelo que a gente
foi entender que a vida é cheia de
novidades de altos e baixos de acertos e
erros
a vida como ela é talvez dessa maneira a
gente tem a coragem de expressar nossos
sentimentos
a gente tem a coragem de levar uma
verdadeira para nós mesmos
tenha coragem de fazer a opção de estar
mais com os amigos e que a gente não
tenha no final da vida a queixa de ter
sido menos feliz eu queria lembrar
daqueles daquele espaço de 40 por cento
com três frases de volterra que falava
muito sobre felicidade
o maior problema é o único que nos
devemos preocupar é de ser feliz
uma segunda frase de voltar dizia eu
escolhi ser feliz porque se feliz faz
bem pra mim a saúde e para finalizar
voltar também falou
devemos cuidar do nosso jardim muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]